drink responsibly wash down every chip
and or wings during Super Bowl 58 with
these beer cocktails for the 49ers we
got a lighter chamoy mango mishela so
start with some lime juice and some
chamoy sauce before adding your choice
of logger toped some mango juice no salt
needed here a bit sweeter than the
average michelada but ideal for refills
for the Chiefs we're making beer punch
grab a picture and add some pineapple
juice ginger ale a logger of your choice
and some fruit punch give it a nice
swirl and serve we're hoping these quick
and easy to make drink had a bit more
excitement for you and your guest during
the big game please